what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest epic developments in
the one piece story we got more of luffy
versus kaido and an insane
yonko twist so make sure to stay tuned
for that if you do enjoy these one-piece
reviews it would be awesome if you could
take a second to hit that like button
it means a lot if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you actually get notified when the
next chapter drops
while you wait for the next video to
come out feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist which
includes videos on all yonko
warlords supernova and more link to that
is in the description now without
further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
we got one piece as the central focus of
this week shown in jump cover again
always love to see this we're told that
the momentous showdown with the emperors
is finally heating up
and at this point you might even want to
refer to luffy as one of the emperors
that they're talking about my hero
academia black clover and jujutsu kaizen
are prominent
too i always appreciate seeing these
creative covers and crossovers
but on the chapter itself the title is
onco standards and onco
is translated as red bean paste which is
used to make
oshiruko soup kind of random yes but
also relevant and significant as we'll
see
we got kit and killer dealing with yonko
big mom
they're surprised to see lightning since
zeus is trapped and interestingly enough
big mom says let's see what you can do
show me your power
hera before the lightning attack is
unleashed i love the greek mythology
references
and in mythology hera is zeus's sister
and wife
we also see a pair of feminine lips
answer big mom
before the attack is unleashed
suggesting that prometheus might have
been suggesting to big mom previously
that she create a new more reliable
homie that can replace
zeus who tends to drop the ball the
implications
are pretty huge here in addition to
getting to see
hera's new powers zeus is now seemingly
available for nami
which is exactly the reunion i wanted to
see so i'm very hyped about these
developments
the attack that hera unleashes is called
fulgora aka the female personification
of lightning in roman mythology the
blast is enough to get the metal cube
holding zeus to fall apart i can't help
but feeling kind of bad for zeus here as
he's asking if his mom
is okay and he's clearly concerned but
in all likelihood he's already been
replaced in the meantime our boy law is
helping zoro and tells luffy that he's
taking everyone with him leaving luffy
by himself
to take on kaido just as luffy asked for
i was mentioning this last chapter as
well but i love how crazy luffy is and
how excited he gets in these situations
that would practically freak out
everyone else and this time
kaido straight up points that out when
he mentions that luffy seems to enjoy
this
the greater the risk the wider luffy's
smile and it's so
true dudes alone with the man dubbed the
strongest creature in the world and he's
got a giant smile across his face what a
great role model for how anyone should
act in challenging circumstances
why worry when you can view it as a more
or less exciting way to see what you're
truly capable of we again get one of
these epic conquerors hockey clashes
where they don't even make direct
contact at the beginning of this arc i
gotta admit i was hesitant to consider
luffy an emperor yet
but now after everything we've seen he's
definitely earned a title in my mind
not just through infamous deeds but
through pure power as well
and by the end of the fight who knows
perhaps he even surpasses it
meanwhile kit and killer got blown
inside the castle
it's good to see that they're pretty
fine and unaffected by the attack
yes they got sent flying pretty far but
it's nothing they
can't walk away from and we got another
big mom flex
when it's pointed out that the hole she
created was so massive
she can't even tell which way she sent
these two flying
kid is in a hurry to find her not
wanting to let her regroup with kaido he
can't let his fellow buddy captain luffy
take on both of them
by himself after all we get a surprise
appearance by
hawkins who stops kid and killer from
advancing with his straw sword
you can't beat kids greeting here when
he says to hawkins and i quote
you've got balls if you think you can
get in our way you rat
end quote i absolutely love these
interactions between the supernova and
my first thought here was there's no way
i want to see kid having any trouble
with hawkins and fortunately enough
killer quickly offers to take him on
supernova versus supernova and that's
another sign of how impressive kid's
crew is
his crew member albeit a supernova will
deal with the supernova captain himself
having more than one supernova on your
crew is such a flex in this world and i
love to see it
kid trusts killer to handle it and this
actually works out for hawkins
as he says that his odds of
simultaneously suppressing both of them
were very unfavorable this guy is still
all about the odds
i find this conversation very
interesting hawkins has a specific
philosophy
in his mind apu had already sold them
out defeat was inevitable resistance
futile
in his view he made the only possible
choice and then he adds that it's
extraordinary that kid and killer
survive
having made the opposite choice and
based on his philosophy
of always playing the odds you can
obviously see why he'd back
to yonko against some supernova on paper
this really did look impossible but
there's more to life than just doing
what's most likely to succeed
and doing what's most likely to ensure
your own survival from killer's point of
view
he just sees a dude who's embraced his
role as a guard dog
hawkins is not acting with honor but
rather with cowardice since he's just
teaming up with kaido
because he wants to be on the winning
side he says that killer's chance of
getting killed
is 92 percent but that doesn't bother
killer since unlike hawkins
he doesn't rely on fortune and takes
matters into his own hands i absolutely
love it when hawkins tells him he can
only wish for luck
and killer replies screw you and your
luck
i'm not wishing for anything killer has
never been cooler in my view
this is such a great mentality to have
and you know which side oda would be on
as someone who tried to make it as a
mangaka which people probably told him
was next to impossible
but he gave it a shot anyways and one
piece became the best selling manga of
all time
you never know what can happen if you
don't try if he had the philosophy of
hawkins he never would have even tried
to pursue his dream
so yeah my money is on killer for this
match my money is on the eight percent
or at least a tie
place your bets whatever happens i think
it's better to be someone who loses with
honor living by your principles
than it is to be someone who wins by
kissing up two and becoming a slave to a
stronger person
we then jump to usopp tama and nami
being chased by the oh so resilient page
1.
it's a pretty one-sided battle at this
point page 1 is chasing them and hanging
on to komachio
as they beg him to go away tama has a
plan
soon they should get to the live floor
stage where horcella
love that name should have fed thomas
dongos to a lot of bad guys
guys who will become their allies thanks
to thomas abilities
you gotta respect the kids like momo and
tama here
tama even says that all that matters is
she helps by turning those guys into
allies
then it doesn't matter what happens to
her we get a hilarious moment where nami
and usa promise to protect her but
what's funny is that nami refers to
herself as big sister
and to usopp as an uncle to which usopps
like hey i'm only 19 years old no matter
how dire the situation
you can count on these guys having funny
interactions
then usopp steps up and promises to take
care of it
he uses the move flower fireworks which
to his legendary credit
actually makes page one let go he turned
the page if you will
usa promises to finish him off and
launches his exploding pinecones attack
he has a very epic pose as he
confidently asks
how do you like them apples to the
obliterated page one
except page one of course is fine and
gets up and then they freak out all over
again
that he's back up usopp not looking
quite as cool or confident as he did a
second ago
they have no idea how they can handle
this dinosaur type that keeps getting up
and cannot be turned using a dongle
because he didn't eat a smile
as if things weren't bad enough guess
who appears to their left
none other than yonko big mom herself
nami and usop's expressions
are absolutely hilarious here imagine
being stuck between a dino rock and a
yonko
at first big mom is focusing on our
straw hats but luckily tama brightens
her
mood and as prometheus points out she's
gone into mothering mode
a mode she enters when around kids under
10 years old i love seeing these
opposite sides of big mom
just because she can be a formidable
yonko doesn't mean she can't be nice and
protective over
kids so let's see how her friendship
with tama plays out i'm glad to see that
even with her memories returned their
friendship is still going strong
big mom even thanks tama for looking
after her back when she had amnesia
before going on let me just say how
unbelievably useful has tama been in
this fight
full props to mvp tama here but back to
their conversation big mom says with a
big smile on her face that she'll never
forget the flavor of the oshiruko soup
that poor otsuru gave her in okobora
town
so there's a connection to the title
that soup itself had a big
impact on big mom and that impact that
little moment of kindness
will now shape her actions and perhaps
the future of the entire battle as
well tama tells her with tears in her
eyes that that town is gone now the town
was burnt to the ground
remembering otsuru's kindness and seeing
thomas tears
big mom is enraged she's enraged at
kaido's
underlings did that to the people who
showed her hospitality and with that
revelation
when page one goes to finish off our
guise big mom says that the pirate world
may be cruel
but there are still standards and she
one shots page one calling him a vermin
this is huge we were predicting that
there may be a rift between big mom and
kaido since the beginning of the
alliance and it appears to have happened
we can't jump the gun and say for sure
that big mom will help take down kaido
but who knows where this move could lead
it is possible she keeps going
it is possible kaido's men attack her
after what she did
and she beats them up ulti is there so
the way they react to each other will be
crucial and
zeus has showed up too and since nami is
here
i expect to see that reunion happen
sooner rather than later
what a chapter though something hawkins
can't predict is a situation like this
where a yonko gets amnesia befriends a
little girl and is willing to attack her
partner's side because of that
relationship
ultimately you can't live off of
probability because anything can happen
and one piece is a constant reminder of
that and i am so excited to see what's
going to happen next i just hope that
kid is smart enough to stay back
and see whether big mom's going to take
out any more
of kaido's underlings before he tries
anything things have definitely never
looked better for our side than right
now
and it's exhilarating but anyways that
is it for this chapter thanks so much
for watching and i hope you enjoyed it
as much as i did
who's your mvp this time around let me
know is it tama or perhaps
big mom herself who definitely helped us
out more than we expected this chapter
if you did enjoy the review help out the
channel by smashing that like button
just like big mom smashed page one if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you actually
get notified for the next one piece
video while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist which
includes detailed videos on all the
yonko warlords supernova and more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patrons of
legend the ones acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself alpha sigma red-haired
raven and
av and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand atop
all clans ingrada pate heffa al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi bang emperor
otaku spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist
and yuno and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazowski
cricket xp rethuan dei aura very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water joanne garcia ted note 10
i sparky 65 jessica lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
and soul rise slice and dice thank you
all so much if you do enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime outdoor link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
by clicking that blue join button next
to subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you